let's move to the big TV news Mirai Kari
called her time on American Idol the
worst experience of her life no that has
a lot of people asking is Mariah getting
her idol revenge by appearing on The
Voice we got Mariah freaking Carey yo
you guys Jay hood now we're more excited
than anyone else oh my god the process
working with these four awesome coaches
was just like everyday I learned
something new
no drama darling and definitely no
clashing with the ladies of the voice
because who needs a repeat of the woman
versus woman nastiness she had with
Nicki Minaj on Idol oh and I was about
to say
Mariah's 3 episode run as a nuthouse
advisor is definitely a win-win it's
sure to boost ratings for the voice and
provide love for her upcoming new album
I'm sitting there taking her advice
while she's talking to them like I'm in
some kind of Mariah Carey course it
feels like yesterday I was a backup
singer traveling around doing stuff this
car
[Laughter]
as for why Mimi decided to return to a
competition show well it's all about her
passion for music for me there was never
another option it was just always this
whether or not I did go to beauty school
which is the truth but that was in high
school
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]